good morning everyone I'm delighted to
be with you so like you said my name is
Dallin Harris
I'm with skyhook interactive we're a web
site development firm here in town
and I want to talk today about five
trends that will shape the web over the
next five years and you know why should
you listen to me why should I have any
credibility basically my job every day
is to talk to new customers who are
coming in and ask what it is that they
want on their website or what it is
they're trying to accomplish in their
business and having that conversation
once or twice a day for the last 10
years I've talked to over a thousand
people and and really have developed a
sense I take copious notes as I talk
with these people and I've kind of
developed a sense I think for what's
coming and what people are asking for
which i think is a good indicator of the
trends that we'll see in the near future
so good website strategists work hard to
identify trends so they can exploit them
good website strategists work hard to
identify trends so they can exploit them
in terms of things we're gonna hit today
I want to talk about this concept of
risk risk is I've I'm gonna share some
information I think that has kind of
changed my mind how I look at risk how
it's a good thing and how we can
understand it and manage it and I think
it's the foundation for being able to
see trends coming we're going to talk
about what common risks are the
different customers have I'm gonna share
with you five of my favorite trends that
I think are coming in website
development but again with this
foundation you can hopefully see others
that are coming and and start to do the
next point which is how to identify
trends yourself and we'll have some
discussion around that and we'll be done
so let me let me hit this quote so Peter
Drucker said all profit is derived from
risk and when I first heard this I don't
think I fully understood what he was
saying but in time as I've thought about
it I think it's it's one of the smartest
things he ever said so I don't know if
you've ever asked yourself as a service
provider why do my customers hire me
instead of doing it themselves
and the answer is because in their
business in their world in all of the
problems they're trying to solve there
are specific parts of that that they are
not equipped to do because they haven't
had experience around that and it would
be risky for them to try to do it
themselves so I'm gonna I'm gonna tell
you a story that hopefully illustrates
this I have a good friend his name's Joe
he decided 10 years ago ish to start a
chair and table rental business here in
the Phoenix area
it's called royalty rentals and if you
put yourself in Joe's shoes for a little
bit starting that business there's a lot
of things he's got to figure out where
do I get tables where do I get chairs
where do I get linens how do I set up my
warehouse so things can come in and out
how do I set up my accounting how do I
do marketing so that people will
actually find my business how do I build
a website how do I keep track of all
this inventory how do I hire employees
how do I do performance management and
maybe have to fire some employees if it
doesn't work out all of these things for
a first-time business owner represent
individual risks the which if they're
not managed properly could mess the
whole thing up right like if he's just
terrible at hiring people and he never
figures out how to do that the rest of
the business can't be successful because
of that problem so business owners
definitely have this I would argue that
even internally inside of companies
people who are trying to get things done
they look at their whole job and there's
little parts of it that that they can't
be successful if those pieces aren't
executed properly and those represent
risks to their ultimate success so in
Joe's case he started looking at his
website and his inventory tracking
system and said I could probably figure
that out but it would take me a really
long time I'm not a programmer I'm not a
user experience designer I don't know
anything about the web and how hosting
works so I'm just gonna hire someone who
can process this little bit of risk
better than I can I'm not asking them to
take responsibility for my whole
enterprise but this little piece of it
is better handled by someone who can
handle that risk better so that that
core concept that that little nugget to
realize that your customers have or
internally if you if you're working with
an
team they have risks that they are not
as well-equipped to handle as you are
that forms the basis of need for you to
be able to come in and provide a service
which then entitles you to a piece of
the profit of that whole business which
is which is where profit comes from so
my contention here this morning is if we
can get really good at understanding
what our customers risk actually is what
it is they're actually hiring us to do
that gives us the key that then unlocks
our ability to predict the future
because we can see the sorts of kinds of
things that they're gonna need and when
new things come along we can kind of
check that against well I know customers
are hiring us to solve this kind of risk
and I can see how that would solve it
and we can start to get good at at
quote-unquote predicting the future you
follow me so far okay so so this kind of
summarize that point the best way to
prepare for the future is to be laser
focused on understanding your customers
risk the best way to prepare for the
future is to be laser focused on
understanding your customers risk so as
I mentioned I do this this thing daily
where I talk to potential customers and
I'm trying to understand what their risk
is and over thousand over a thousand of
these kinds of conversations and I went
back in preparation for this note and
looked at a lot of my notes and tried to
draw out patterns I find that the risk
that people are trying to solve or have
have processed for them when they hire a
website developer falls into one of two
categories either they are looking for a
website that can be a spokesperson for
their company or they're looking for a
website that can be a service man for
their company and let me let me kind of
explain what I mean by that if you're a
company and you're hiring a spokesman or
a spokeswoman you want them to be
everywhere you want them looking good
you want them to be persuasive you want
them to speak in a way that gets people
excited about your business and and then
paints you in a positive light right
that's the job of a spokesman a service
man you want them to show up without
fail do the job
provide Pleasant customer service and
and do that consistently every day like
that's
the job of someone who's providing a
service and if you think about it as I
think about a website effectively does
this a website is a spokesperson for a
brand that's out there 24/7 preaching
the good word of whatever that
particular business does hopefully
helping customers feel at ease and
communicating what that brand does and
just generally converting people to that
you know the services that business does
and it's also like a like ice in some
cases it's more like a service man you
think of like applications and I'll get
into some specific examples here but the
website should just be there 24/7
providing the service educating people
and in so I kind of break it into those
two paradigms let me let me break that
down just a little bit further so a
spokesman
I'll give you well let me tell the story
here so we did we were involved in an
RFP for the Tempe office of tourism
which we didn't actually end up winning
but to me they were the quintessential
example of needing a spokesman so you
think of the City of Tempe it's a town
here for those who aren't local where
the where Arizona State is you think of
the City of Tempe what is the Office of
Tourism need to do they need to impress
people who aren't from here to kind of
highlight the vibe of Tempe and the
amenities that are available in the
hotels and the and the lake and the
sporting events and you know why you
should want to come and visit Tempe or
do business in Tempe or host your event
in Tempe they're really just trying to
paint the picture of this amazing town
which those of us who are here know we
we love Tempe it's got this kind of like
young college vibe and this energy about
it so their website needs to be a
spokesman for Tempe and when you think
of the job they're trying to get done
with that the risk they have is well we
don't really know how to build websites
we've know Tempe but we don't really
know how to build websites
we're not creative maybe we are worried
that if we did it ourselves maybe it
would be slow or it would be hard for
users to navigate like we could probably
get Wix or something do it ourselves and
set it up but it's probably not going to
be like the vibe we're trying to
communicate and people might get the
wrong idea about Tempe
so if you think about that they want
results they want a site that actually
gets people excited about the city of
tempe there's a creative expression
piece and you probably see this a lot
with your clients they're not artists
they're not an artsy kind of people they
afraid to put pen to paper and draw
something or create something visually
because what if people don't like it I
think we all understand that this this
is a very common one search rankings
right they they need it to fare well in
the search engines and you know even
though my firm doesn't actually do this
it's it's something people are
constantly asking about I don't see that
going away that they need to know that
their new site is gonna be found on
Google and and really what they're
trying to build is an effective platform
for marketing because the city of tempe
is gonna be doing all kinds you know for
the next five years
well next forever but the lifetime of
this site they're gonna be hosting
events and they're gonna be posting new
hotels and and highlighting sponsors and
they need they need a website where all
this stuff can live where they can drive
their Instagram traffic where they can
drive their paid search traffic and they
need it they need kind of a hub from
which to launch their marketing
campaigns so again I share all this to
say if we can really understand the
risks that our customers are looking to
us to solve for them we can start to get
a good prediction of what's coming so
I'll get to that the service man analogy
you know think of so my story here is I
got another client we have it's a brand
called Altos and these guys really
interesting model
they've been coaches in track and field
at the Olympic level for like 30 years
they've coached something like 70 gold
medal winners over the course of their
career extremely high-end coaching these
guys understand nutrition they
understand physiology they understand
physics they understand psychology and
they're coaching these these athletes at
the highest level but they're getting
towards maybe the back end of their
career and they're wanting to transmit
all of this knowledge that they've
learned from years of doing this to the
rising generation of college and high
school coaches about track and field so
they've started this brain
and where they've captured they're
learning over like a hundred and fifty
modules of learning that they're trying
to deliver online to these coaches who
can pay a few hundred bucks and come and
take one of these courses so if you
think of that website it's it's got a
spokesman component because they've got
to sell these these new these courses to
people who don't know them but really
it's a service it's a service delivery
website so they're worried about things
like are we actually delivering good
content is is the video link working are
people able to log in if they need to
reset their password does that work
because the last thing they want is you
know hundreds of these customers calling
and saying I can't access the videos or
I can't get my password like they need
the website to just provide all of that
service flawlessly so they're thinking
about things like user experience they
want to be sure that when customers come
onto the site it's just easy and
intuitive and again that these customers
don't have to call with our questions
because it would it would overrun them
and they're also thinking about okay
what's down the road phase one we want
to put this content out there but maybe
down the road we want to have a
community or these people can chat with
each other
maybe we want to have an event calendar
if we want to host in-person events like
they're there phase one of this for them
is just literally get the education out
but they're also thinking like what's
our product roadmap so again I highlight
all of this to say understand the risk
that your customers are hiring you to do
and these guys they're they're brilliant
people they coach at the Olympic level I
mean very very good at their craft but
they don't understand websites and
hosting and Technology and and how to
make a good user experience so that's
why they would look to an outside firm
both customers I want to highlight
something that both kind of customer
types have in common
the first one is assembling the right
team and that kind of goes good with the
second one which is looking good to
their boss or to their teammates this
one kind of surprised me we had just
finished a website for a local brand and
I was talking with the marketing
director to get her feedback on how she
thought it went and she said
you know I'm so happy with the new
website I feel like I finally have a
voice on the executive team I thought
that was an interesting why did she take
it there but basically what had happened
is the website project had gone so well
and everyone internally thought it was
so cool that they were like wow you know
they gained respect they liked it made
her look good and I thought duh like
that's that's something our customers
are thinking about and they want to make
sure when they pick a firm that they
don't pick someone who's gonna blow it
because they're in some level putting
their career on the line or at least you
know their reputation I thought that was
interesting time efficiency again we've
kind of talked about this I have another
client who actually could do a lot of
this but I would just take him you know
three to five times as long as it would
take someone else so it's it makes more
economic sense to outsource it and then
increasingly and always speed you know
they're they're taking a risk that
you're gonna build a fast website
security but it's not gonna get hacked
because that's the thing unfortunately
in 2019 and uptime those kinds of things
so I hope I'm connecting the dots here
you understand the customers risk and
you can start to see why some of the
trends make more sense so back to that
product adoption curve and trying to see
what's coming down the pike and
comparing it against what we know our
customers are worried about obviously
the you know there's some things that as
I think of the next five years to me are
obvious but I'll just state them we're
gonna go on to more interesting ones but
speed I think until the web's the
Internet is as fast as changing channels
on a TV we're gonna continue to need and
see speed improvements so that's a big
area for the next five years security
there's more hackers and more malware
and and and just more general ugliness
out there than ever and WordPress is
kind of a one downside because it's got
such a big target on its back it's it's
the one to hack if you can act WordPress
you can hack a lot of sites and so it's
kind of this constant cat-and-mouse game
but security has a bright future
flawless user experience you know we go
when we use Facebook and we use
Instagram and we use Google these
billion-dollar products that are
very carefully thought-out and they have
these amazing user experiences that
creates a lot of pressure on those of us
who are building more smaller business
websites because users start to expect a
flawless user experience I think that
will continue to to be the case mobile
first obviously non coder tools I've
observed this before I think as
programmers and I identify to some
extent as a programmer I studied
computer science in college I think
we're always in the business of like
building ourselves out of a job like we
make these new tools and now suddenly
we're not needed anymore because the
customers can just use the tools and
they don't need to hire us so I see
things like Gutenberg and and you know
even WordPress itself is a good example
of this like there's less and less need
for like hardcore programming and I see
a trend towards tools that can do these
kinds of things for people not to say
programmers won't have a job we just
have to dig deeper into more complex
problems inclusive design which is kind
of accessibility standards things like
that taking into consideration people
with disabilities that'll continue to be
a trend and those are kind of the big
obvious ones I want to talk about a
couple that are maybe a little bit less
obvious but are maybe more on the what
is that the visionary like that I'm
trying to hit like the up ramp the
things that that I think will be big in
the next three to five years
the first one is brand and communication
strategy for as long as I've been
building websites I don't know if you
guys hear this but from our customers
it's oh I can provide the content you
guys just do the design and it's like
okay great you know the program room is
like okay whatever you you provide the
content but first of all they're not
very good at it it takes it forever and
in at the end of the day their content
doesn't really convert and in it's it's
too esoteric that you know they know
their world they're speaking their own
language they're not talking to a
broader audience like you you I'm seeing
nodding heads out there you guys all get
this here's my observation the world is
shrinking and what I mean by that is
it's literally as easy to do business
now with someone on the other side of
the country as it is
to do business with your next-door
neighbor it doesn't really matter where
you're at geographically and
consequently
you are immediately now competing you
know most of the businesses we do web
sites for are now competing at a
national scale so it's not enough to
just say I'm a lawyer here in Tempe you
got to defend yourself a little more
than that because it's easy for me to
hire a lawyer pretty much anywhere I
mean that's a bad example because
there's Bar Association's and things but
it's you got to be able to tell me why
you're unique and in the whole world for
for what you do because it's easy for me
to do business anywhere in the world
which consequently means your brand
can't just be I'm the local guy who does
this or girl who does this you've got to
be different and that to me is good
copywriting it's good brand strategy
it's researching what makes you or your
client unique and different and that's
something that if they write the content
themselves they're just not even gonna
even gonna see so honestly if I'm if I'm
trying to invest in a high converting
website graphic design is important but
content is more important it's got to
have the right message that actually
resonates with the target audience you
guys probably seen this Amazon is like
eating the world and little ecommerce
folks are like getting beat up retailers
everywhere getting beat up by this like
monster but then you see brands like
Zappos or Warby Parker come along and
they're actually making headway and the
reason is they're like well Amazon's
great but they don't know shoes like we
know shoes or they don't know I wear
like we do and that's an example of a
brand story that's able to carve out and
defend themselves against global
competition but I see this so happening
even more over the next 3-5 years
clients are realizing that they
shouldn't be doing content themselves
and and I think there's a bright future
for for branded communication strategy
trend number two with a bright future
continuous development you know again
looking back there's this pattern of
every five years we redo the whole
website we spend a bunch of money and
then we don't touch it for five years
and by year four it's getting like
cobwebs and stale everywhere and
everyone's kind of embarrassed of the
site and that's like yeah we really
should do something about that and
they finally get around to doing a big
overhaul again I see us getting away
from that large companies see their
website as a continuous development
effort and I think smaller companies are
starting to see that too
and at skyhook we've we started a couple
two or three years ago we started
offering these and no one would buy them
but now they're they're starting to buy
them this idea of a week a lot of
performance management plan or a
continuous development retainer where
it's like hey we're gonna take over your
site and every six months we're gonna
come in we're gonna talk to you we're
going to look at your customers we're
gonna make some tweaks some updates
maybe even some kind of significant
changes to the site and you're gonna be
good for another six months and you're
gonna spend a smaller amount of money
more frequently to make sure that your
website's always up to date as opposed
to this big insane overhaul process and
and customers are starting to accept
that sales pitch and even asking for it
I had someone just last week come in and
say I know I'm gonna be doing all kinds
of updates to this thing so let's just
get you guys on retainer and and we can
chip away at us so I think I think
there's a bright future for continuous
development trend number three
personalization and sales enablement
we're getting really good as marketers
at tracking everything that's happening
and being able to actually do things
with that data so I see a bright future
for things like hey someone came on our
website and they clicked on these pages
so we kind of know who they are and what
they're interested in and maybe we're
showing slightly different images or
maybe slightly different copy -
personally I don't understand there's
like big Google implications to all this
and I don't know how we're gonna sort
that out but the idea is personalizing
the digital experience to the person
based on what we know about them it
could be stuff we know from our crm it
could be stuff we know from our
analytics or just from their literal
behavior patterns while they're on the
site so personalization I think has a
bright future we have a client an
ophthalmology group that's like super
interested in this right now how can we
you know someone came on our site they
saw this ad how can we tailor and
understand kind of their demographic and
are they here for LASIK surgery or a
cataract
surgery and how do we show you know our
studies show that the younger crowd is
more interested in what their friends
think the older crowd is more interested
in having a reliable trusting doctor
that they trust so how do we show just
through the artwork we use and the
messaging we use how do we kind of
tailor based on who they are
personalization has a bright future the
to me the other edge or the other side
of that coin is sales enablement which
sounds something like this when someone
actually does call into the business the
call center or whoever's taking that
call can look at the CRM and say hmm I
see you've been on our site I see you've
looked at these in these pages and they
can kind of have a sense of who this
person is my business partner and I were
on the call the other day with with
another friend and and it was kind of
funny how he was he was we were talking
about this this potential customer and
he's like well let me let me dig into
them and he looked he's like located
been on my site they've downloaded this
they downloaded that and they have a
lead score of 30 which means they're
never gonna buy from me like he just he
knew all of that about this customer
because he could tell what they had
looked at and I thought that's cool
enabling the sales team with insights
that they've the marketing team has been
able to come up with so bright future
for that um I don't know what trend
we're on now number four I think
structured data and Web Services you
notice now there's a chick-fil-a around
they are office I eat there like three
times a week and the app is so cool
because I don't have to wait in the line
I just order what I want and then I walk
up and take it away from the counter and
to me that's an example of a business
starting to offer its service without a
human interaction it's starting to offer
it through like a through a digital
interaction you can see other examples
of this there's these new forget even
the name of them now but like Facebook
has one and Google has one these visual
search kind of it's like a Google home
but with a home hub I think it's like
you can actually see hey Google you know
what what does this restaurant menu have
and in order for that to work Google has
to be able to go and read that what
restaurants web site understand that
what it's seeing is a menu and pull the
images and the text out of that and then
display it so it's really not a human
looking at that restaurants web site
it's a robot looking at that
right restaurants website and
understanding because of the structured
data or because the services are
available like how to present its
information so I see us starting to go
beyond just that human interaction with
the website and understanding that
machines are looking at our websites too
and in some cases maybe even making the
request I can see a future where you
know hey hey Google just activate
everyone's Google devices hey Google
book me a haircutting appointment for
Thursday at 3:00 and it's literally
going to that service seeing if one's
available machines are working it all
out and then it's responding back like
okay yeah got it so that's a trend I see
a bright future
this one's maybe not bright but users
fight back right like you got to be you
got to be careful doing anything on your
on your website that makes things hard
on the user you know they try to come
out with ads and now users have ad
blockers we try to put cookies to track
everyone and now they have cookie
blockers in gdpr
you know we try to track their email and
now Gmail blocks email trackers like and
spam filters and and coupon finders and
these things like I think we have to
understand that users have rights and
that they're gonna fight back against
those kinds of things so I just always
nervous of any technology or idea that's
like usurping the users power because
they they fight back
last one I want to hit and then we can
talk about I want to leave time for your
questions and comments on this as well
this is kind of a bonus number six trend
in in website development over the next
five years there are a lot more service
providers like all of us there's a lot
of web shops out there and you this was
actually a throwback to my talk two
years ago but we got to find a way to
differentiate ourselves you can't just
go in and say I'm a website developer I
build whatever for whoever I see a trend
towards firms that specialize and say
we're experts at this particular
industry or this particular type of
client I see customers hiring
choosing between two web firms that may
come down to culture you know they both
offer the same services but I just like
these people better wood click more and
so I see us talking more about our
particular style and our particular way
of doing things and our point of view
they just some customers probably hear
me speak and think I don't I don't agree
with anything that guy said so I'm gonna
hire someone else and that's fine you
know I'm looking for the ones that see
things my way
so those are trends with a bright future
I want to pause there for just a second
I have a little bit more I want to hit
about how you can identify trends
yourself and how you can kind of develop
this pattern of of seeing what's coming
but before they do I do that I want to
pause and ask any aha moments anything
you would have said differently anything
you feel like I totally missed any
questions let's take maybe five or six
minutes here and do that and then all
and then I'll wrap up with the rest of
the slides right up front here we've got
a mic too so that we can Austin do you
mind that way the the folks who are
watching the recording can hear what
said thank you I was just curious how
aggressive you are on gdpr and AD a
compliance for existing customers who
have that that's a good question
I believe in it I believe it's a trend I
believe it's being recorded there's a
liability question that I think the
client has to answer right like are they
gonna get in trouble for not having it
personally I would advocate for it
absolutely and if we look at the
analytics and see that some something
like 15% of website users have some kind
of a disability I kind of think you're
missing the boat if you don't address
that but it's a it's a sliding scale
right like you can do the most obvious
things high contrast colors and font
sizes and those kinds of things or you
can get you know really extreme and
follow the entire letter of the law
I'm definitely advocating for it more so
on the ad a compliance I think that on
the gdpr side honestly
however like in certain cases we're
doing some work for a university client
and
it's like universities are being sued
for not having these things in place so
you guys got to do something about this
I'm trying trying to walk that balance
of like responding to what customers
need and what I think that budget for
and and also you know if I come out with
a twenty thousand dollar line item for
that like a lot of them just aren't
doing it sorry hold on one second I want
to make sure the audio is captured Thank
You Austin
excellent presentation I thank you I was
wondering how you think that two big
trends AI artificial intelligence and
video will play out with WordPress great
question um AI is cool I mean I haven't
had a lot of opportunity to work on it
personally I kind of feel like at least
from what I've seen this is my literal
experience that's something that like
the big companies and the big budgets
that it takes to invest to do that right
but I could see I don't think this is
five years I think it's further down the
road but you know we've we've heard tale
of like the website that optimizes
itself right because it's just sitting
there running split tests and trying
different messaging I could see that
happening
I could see definitely maybe earlier
even than that I could see on we call it
performance marketing right like we're
tracking all this data on our customers
we're trying to make sense of it
machine learning AI turning it loose on
those data sets and starting to do the
call I think identity resolution which
is you know we see some loose patterns
of how this person's behaving and where
they came from and we kind of know their
IP address can we figure out who they
are and where third-party data sources
from Experian and and others like I can
see it's kind of scary but like we're
all friends here right marketers it's
like yeah I can I could see AI starting
to figure out I know who that person is
and I know what else they're shopping
for and we can personalize that message
so cool cool stuff I'm kind of like Elon
Musk a little bit and like What did he
say AI poses the greatest existential
threat to humans I'm a little bit like
let's let's be careful what we're doing
with that
but yeah I think it's an undeniable part
of what's coming problem probably I
think it'll be more in five years before
it really affects us but I'd be loved to
be I'd love to be told I'm wrong if
someone here knows more about that we're
gonna do you mind in Austin yeah we're
gonna we're gonna wear austin out this
morning
great presentation thank you you talked
about which I totally agree with you
know defining our niche carving out you
know differentiating ourselves as
service providers which I've done kind
of and so my question is that I've been
coming up more and more that now what
about conflicts of interest when I'm
differentiating myself in such a niche
that hey now my clients competitor is
calling me and saying can you do the
same thing for me you know and they're
in this same industry same town or
whatever so yeah I'm dealing with that a
lot and not sure how to handle that I
heard someone say once if an agency has
two customers in a given niche it's a
conflict of interest and if they have
three or more it's a subspecialty
expertise niche it's like it's like own
it right it's I mean that's something
the client has to accept like if I'm
going to you you might be doing work for
my competitors and there will be a
certain I think group of the customers
that aren't comfortable with that
but I would argue back like you know the
stuff we're doing isn't it's not so
strategic that like I'd be the end of
the world if the same people were
working on both things and I try to
reassure clients like we have a walled
garden like the people who are doing
that or not doing this like we have
we're responsible with your information
we're not gonna like go disclose it to
your competitors but really you're not
hiring us to like figure out your core
business model anyway so it's not like
there's basically I try to dismiss the
threat because and I and I believe that
it should be dismissed because our the
concern because like what I'm bringing
to the table because of my expertise in
what you do is so valuable if you're not
comfortable with it let's let's talk
about how we can maybe mitigate that but
it's more important to have the
expertise then you're gonna go bring
someone else in that knows nothing about
any of this that's my
cents on it okay I want to hit my last
few slides and then with the time that's
remaining we can chat more and I'm gonna
be in the in the room next door to
answer questions as long as you'd like
becoming a trend master how to see these
things coming the first thing is to have
some direct research literally just ask
your customers about their DFS their
desired future state when you're in
there doing a sales conversation anyway
just look around hey what else are you
guys working on you know what else are
you trying to solve where else is what
are the other pain points you know
mister or missus marketing manager that
you're worrying about I find that just
literally while you're already in the
room asking some bigger picture
questions I just want to get aligned I
want to if I'm gonna be making website
recommendations too I want to understand
the rest of the things that you're
worried about so I can maybe help you
with those too like just that little
change right there will help you see a
lot more I think where the trends are
going read a lot I have a feed lease
that I've literally said does anyone use
feedly anymore I still use feedly where
I've got all my all my feeds that I
watch and I'm just kind of just just
trying to understand and see you know
just just reading a lot of current blog
posts I think helps you start to pattern
match narrow your field it's really hard
to be an expert if you say I need to
know about everything but when you can
you can zero in on a particular niche or
a particular demographic or a particular
type of service I think it's easier to
wrap your head around it
collaborate with your architects so I
love to bring to our our architects
which is our lead designer our lead
programmer here's this problem the
clients trying to solve how would you
guys solve this and they're kind of
plugged into what's technically possible
and they can they can help me see like
well if your clients dealing with that
here's the types of solutions that we
think can fix that interview and network
I view other people as a time machine
because if I were to go and try to learn
all this stuff it would take me months
and I might get it wrong but when I can
sit down with someone else who has a
little bit different experience and just
interview them or just ask them about
things they save me all that research
time I think it's super those white
things like WordCamp are great because
you can you can save so much time by
just learning from others
I can't quite see my notes here but do
actual research so I see a lot of
marketing firms getting into this where
they literally send out a survey hey you
know we're we're in the healthcare space
and we're interviewing doctors and and
practice managers on what it is they're
worried about and it's kind of low
fidelity but it's like just send out a
survey offer a $50 gift card get a
hundred responses back and and that that
research can actually start to add to
your intellectual property as a firm
which can be really powerful and then I
would say lastly write and publish for
your own good I think we all have this
guilt that we're walking around with
that we don't write to our blog more
because we know we should and we know
our customers want to hear it but what I
found is that even if no one ever read
it just the act of sitting down to blog
or to write or to prepare a talk like
this it's like it forces you to pull
your thoughts together and form an
opinion which is hugely I mean one of
the main reasons I do it to get up here
and speak forces me to like I know I'm
gonna be questioned on some of those
stuff I better have a good good solid
opinion on it it's been really helpful
so I want to end kind of where I began
with just commending you it's it's a
fast-changing business it's not for the
faint of heart you know I think my
business has probably been reinvented
four or five times in the 12 years we've
been doing it but you really are
building that internet brick by brick
and I just I want to commend you and
encourage you to keep going I mean this
is cool stuff it's the stuff that our
kids and our grandkids years from now
will look back and see that we'd like
actually helped to start this thing
that's made the world so much better you
have a very important job and I commend
you for being here for being open to
learning and for for the hard work
you're putting into this so the last
thing I want to say is that predicting
the future is important and possible
through vigilant continuous attention
and effort predicting the future is
important and possible through vigilant
continuous attention and effort so
that's it let's go get it my name is
Dallin reach out to me with any
questions you have I'd be happy to share
any of the resources that I talked about
today and we're always hiring and
looking for good people to work with a
skyhook so I'd love to talk with you
about that as well thank you very much
[Applause]